because guys like do you
want
some kind of
not a woman
i know the answer is not they stopped
you right there i do want to i do want a
female president trans female no
that'd be fire it's very progressive i
don't divide them up okay
female is female okay and the future is
female
so
so these are all important things that's
fine to be on a shirt but when someone
says it out loud
the future is female but no i would love
a female president that would be fire
but do you want to know on some level i
was working you got to let them finish
you got it i know when a schultz insult
is coming so you got to let them know
i don't have anything i i would like i
think it'd be great i think it'd be a
great for our country yeah do you
remember we had a lot of results
insults
don't you want diversity with a catholic
president with jfk yep yeah that was
diverse yeah
you know i needed that
so i was diverse at the time yeah we
can't elect this [ __ ] catholic he's a
catholic what is he going to do yeah i
don't know if i want to picture my
president being fingered as a child
um
[Laughter]
not all catholics were fingered okay oh
i thought you're talking about some
heart
no i mean like a catholic president all
i picture is like
you know what i mean yeah that's a weird
thing to lead with like i'm catholic
yeah yeah yeah do you think the priest
is like proud of that like
y'all fingered a bunch of opioid addicts
i figured the president
yeah that's crazy
okay but no but seriously tell me why i
know i'm not i don't my
female president whatever you're against
a female president
i was i was working on a bit about how
like do you guys want i don't i want to
know that when a female president is in
office that she's not sucking dicks
you don't want your president suck and
die but like if you're married like
there should be like four years you can
outsource it your husband can have like
a side yes
all only business because i don't want
all of our world leaders to know like
she's not like she could be she has to
service her husband at some point that's
fire yeah yeah she should never be in a
should though subservient
fine
everybody's happier well she could be
lesbians she should be good everyone
would know oh yeah that's true yeah
which that would be perfect lesbian
president fire that yeah
or prime minister for y'all out there if
you don't know what a president is yeah
[ __ ] poor's horse fix your teeth
i don't think we'll have a female in our
lifetime we said the same thing about
black president we did yeah i never said
that
you did it
you never thought
nobody ever asked you but you did you
were a little surprised when it happened
why is he in public right now do you
remember the inauguration when it was
covered with the bulletproof glass yes
that it was wild okay as soon as you saw
the family walk out and then from one
angle you saw like all the reflecting of
the light it was so it gave it like made
me sick to think but wouldn't you think
it'd be great to have a female president
why would a female president be the
right one a bad one would be the worst
thing ever cause no one would ever want
one ever again and like it would be such
a setback i'd say wait till the [ __ ]
perfect one then russian whatever
there's nobody you'd vote for now what
about elizabeth warren she'd be talking
sense michelle obama
michelle nikki haley yeah no chelsea
gabbard yeah shout out to
tulsi i like chelsea a lot i don't know
what ha i feel like there was a weird
little hit job that happened to her oh
yeah right everyone said she was like a
russian bot i don't want to get too
political okay but if we don't talk
about our body no no no no no i'm saying
like if we did have a female president
right yeah
and i understand that you don't want her
giving [ __ ] because you feel like
that's subservient it's more like i just
don't want leaders thinking that's going
on because there's a lot of other
countries that are way further behind
than we are that might look down upon
that mm-hmm
what if what if she's getting [ __ ] in
her ship they might think we're
i was gonna say they made they were weak
if they know it's just [ __ ] box they're
like that's a [ __ ] that's a man
she takes in the ass like a man that's a
boss
i don't think there's anything wrong
with giving blow jobs i think it's a
very empowering thing but do you ever
like it
at all well you're married now so you're
never gonna get no i i i don't remember
what they're like but what i'm saying is
i do remember there was a time where i
felt so weak when i would get a [ __ ]
right i felt like i had no control
whatsoever true because you got i have
two sets of teeth don't do this when you
talk about it
this right here you stopped you really
told this right here you stopped this
immediately okay you gave me some winter
dick
this little pig
don't do that at all that is i guess a
really a power position because you are
holding the most valuable part of your
body in your mouth and you're between
your teeth interesting remember there
was that great chappelle joke no no who
was yeah yeah yeah where the
she was sucking the dick and then she
went to get [ __ ] done
stuck in the president's dick
oh uh we need to lower these taxes
um this is a group oh yeah that was just
killing something it was killing him
softly i think we should really think we
should lower taxes yeah yeah yeah
it was way better when he did that
i'm sorry i even i lobbed it up to you
because i was like i'm gonna butcher it
and then
that was the neatest thing anyone's done
about your pelvis yeah
jesus man okay uh it's it's very funny
go check it out um i just wonder if
there's a female president there's just
certain things we have to let everyone
know
you know like what like just she's not
you know
she's not what she's not going to have
she doesn't have any balls on her chin
for four years she's not going to have
her period oh yeah i don't have to worry
oh that's a good point
i don't know do you think about stuff
like that when there's like a woman
leader do you look at the husband and go
like oh do i look at the husband and go
oh he's got to deal with her or just
something i don't know we've never had a
female problem
like angela merkel yeah her
that was cool do you know sylvia
berlusconi yeah yeah so he do you see i
did a podcast for wandery where i like
narrated it's um uh the whole thing so i
learned a lot about sylvia berlusconi
can you explain who berlusconi was italy
but also like kind of a gangster the
most gay super billionaire controls the
cable networks he basically oh he's
basically trump
they were going to mussolini that [ __ ]
one more time
basically he owned all the tv networks
he put all these like shows like show
girls on um uh and then put them all in
parliament like literally show girls
like he just like bought the country he
bought the football team
soccer whatever the [ __ ] and his slogan
to run for prime minister was go italy
and aligned it with football and that's
the most important thing to them so we
just like people would go like why would
we vote for you and he's like go italy
italy wins only like it's very trump
like trump like loves him um super
corrupt like just a lot of people can't
be excited about his country a lot of
mafia money well no the the the week
that people were in the magistrates were
investigating um his like money
laundering and not paying taxes his
truly four best friends like you you and
you
were all found having just committed
suicide like in their homes like his
three best friends like like the most
crazy [ __ ] were they in orlando
it's okay
great question these are things that we
have to know before we get
conspiratorial on this podcast there's
things that we have to know there's a
video of him calling angela merkel a fat
ass
i mean she's not the best built [ __ ]
i've ever seen in my life but is that
kind of what you want out of a leader
yes sturdy hips
yes i don't even know if she has hips
like cankles yeah she's like um who's
like our hottest leader that we still
respect oh that we respect like a mall
clooney
like who's like how hot can you look at
her hold on how hot can you be and still
be taken seriously no i need you to no i
respect this woman yeah th this she's
gonna get [ __ ] done no kids right
uh
i don't think any kids got a husband no
kids
that is a exactly
haircut you think she has down syndrome
that haircut her barber does
for sure
who is that [ __ ] nfl team owner oh
yeah
al davis al davis mark davis has son
yeah
mark davis yes mark davis yeah she's a
she's an odd one this woman but you
don't have to look that bad is that coco
no this is that's cook isn't that um
ice cube's wife this is the croatian
president this is not interesting i
don't know if this guy's
her body i don't know if this got
debunked or not that looks like coco
iced tea's wife that's a croatian it's
the croatian president you see what i'm
saying
so it is possible okay go there okay
yeah
it is vegas croatia and how serious are
they very big these
what problems is she solving on a daily
basis
all croatia all of them croatia what's
going on four million people in croatia
yeah four million people in croatia okay
four million yeah you have no excuse not
to look like that
this is the listen the president says
got it you need to be an attractive
good-looking man
or woman i'm not pointing at you because
i'm saying you are
i'm just saying that angela merkel is is
representing germany in a way that's
kind of odd do you want that to be the
face of germany the man from up
[Laughter]
you mean the parachute from um
i mean come on
this is not this is not how you want
your country represented but no but she
gets [ __ ] done look at that she's not
busy trying to look good she gets [ __ ]
done i was wondering
this is [ __ ] ratatouille ratatouille
is your president
or prime minister or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
oh no oh god oh god oh god i'm just
curious what brian posane was up to
you know what happened to brian bo's
saying is he's out
here okay um okay can we be serious it's
interesting it'll be i'm not liking we
need a female i'm like don't put any
women in any positions where they're
gonna [ __ ] suck until they're [ __ ]
extra good why because you think we're
gonna go i told you so well no just most
politicians suck women are not right or
are disappointing in some way i mean
think what politicians do we still like
after they served any time barack yeah
that's true george jimmy carter but i
don't know jimmy carter if he drops a
podcast or he's still going to like him
podcast for sure that voice i'd listen
oh yeah okay i feel like he's he's like
one podcast away from people being like
buddy they did do a podcast
he narrated
the lakes the the lip the parks this
thing yeah yeah he narrated that show
yeah called the parks project right yeah
i'm pretty sure and he just told
everybody about the parks that we have
yeah
but it's wild because we're like we're
like hey brock white people know about
that
that got greenlit this is by netflix
that was greenlit by netflix gotcha are
you about to say something about netflix
no not at all i i think that they're
making phenomenal decisions obviously
they made a great decision with you
dropping it on a monday night the night
everybody's
super excited to watch
[Laughter]
you know the problem with netflix is
they they literally just they what is it
called uh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're like um they okay they think
they're like an old italian town where
there's only one restaurant
you know what i mean they're like yeah
we can take a nap during the day because
there's no other place for people to go
yeah yeah but now that there's like a
a bustling city
you have to change things a little bit
you have to learn how to market do you
know what i'm saying yeah and they're
not like dropping it on a monday night
um well here's the thing uh i do make
lots of transphobic jokes in it so
please tune in oh